Speaker 1: Hey, does cancel culture actually exist
in light of the latest right wing cancellation of
the new Eminem's? We have to talk about cancel
culture. Does cancel culture actually exist?
Someone sent me an article from the Center on
a Stateless Society, which is sort of the basis
for this segment. And that article really got me
thinking. And what I mean by does cancel culture
really exist is sometimes things are canceled
in the sense that people are fired or a show is
canceled or someone is ostracized or people change
their views, or activists express opinions that
say, I don't like what you said. That happens,
right? That takes place. But does the cancel
culture that Republicans describe actually exist?
Does this culture exist when Republicans scream,
we are being canceled by the woke left? I
believe that it does not really exist. Often
what is happening is that someone's words
or actions are having consequences as those
words and actions are being evaluated in the
free market of ideas which Republicans claim
to support. Oftentimes the canceled still have a
bully pulpit, plenty of access to corporate media,
social media and other platforms to spread their
views. Sometimes they're canceled in the sense
that they lose when they're entertainers. They
lose one opportunity, but then they come back
and they get another opportunity. And sometimes
it takes a little while. You look at Mel Gibson,
who had this horrible incident where he was pulled
over drunk driving, and he said to the officer,
Are you a Jew? And I guess the officer
was Jewish. You know, what are the odds?
And then he, you know, made all sorts of other
horrible statements. And there was a period
during which Mel Gibson wasn't doing much work
in Hollywood, but like, then he's back. Then he
started getting work again. And so is that
is that really a cancellation? There was a
period during which his statements and actions
impacted his career. It seems logical that in
such a free market, there are consequences
to the things that you say and that you do.
And so often and this is really what I believe
is at the crux of this meme of cancel culture
that the right likes to talk about. Often those
who are accused of doing the canceling are people
from groups that only more recently are getting a
louder voice. They're from previously marginalized
groups. And thanks to social media and the
Internet, some of those individuals, some of
those groups are now having more of a voice to
express their views. People speak out and they
push back against marginalization, and sometimes
there are consequences to the person doing the
marginalizing. And now they have been canceled as
if it's bad that there are consequences for the
things that they have said or done. Now, it's
also worth noting that by their own definition
of canceling, it is often Republicans that are
doing the canceling, despite the fact that they
say it's the left that does the canceling. And
we see this in the way that they try to silence
dissenting voices in the media and in academia and
in politics. They want to control the narrative.
They want to shut down voices that challenge
their ideology. And when they get called out,
they say it's cancel culture as a way to deflect
responsibility and to play the victim everything
they accuse the left of doing, they do. Let
me remind you of something else. This isn't
as popular in the last couple of years,
but you used to often hear from the right.
Saying you're offended isn't an argument. And
I agreed with them. Right. If someone makes
a statement and someone on the left or the
right responds by saying that's offensive.
Boom. Conversation over. I think that
that is a way to shut down an argument,
to shut down debate. And it's not actually
an argument in and of itself. You offended
me. Boom. Well, let's let's talk about what
I said. Let's talk about white. White. Okay.
That's cancel culture is exactly the same thing.
It is exactly equivalent to I'm offended. And the
conversation that's cancel culture. That's it.
We're done. It's exactly the same thing now.
I'll be upfront with everybody here. You all
know I am not blind to the reality that sometimes
people may go too far in their activism. Sometimes
the calls for someone's head are premature or they
are inappropriate. If we go back and think
about, by the way, when Democrats demanded
that their own Senator, Al Franken, resign. Al
Franken participated in a tasteless joke that
was photographed and it was tasteless. There's no
question about it. But in a sense, Democrats were
too quick to say you got to resign Al Franken,
partially because Democrats wanted to show how
how fair and nonpartisan they were when it came
to these things. And the reality is that what Al
Franken did was really quite minor compared to
the things others have gotten away with. So I'm
not blind to the fact that sometimes people go too
far, but that doesn't mean you can't hold anyone
accountable. And if you do, it's cancel culture.
So we need to shift from calling people out to.
It's so cliche like sometimes that people say
we need to call people in to talk. Right. This
is all the reality of there are now many
more platforms on which people can speak
and there are many more platforms on which people
can respond to speech. And so that's the reality.
And so the idea of cancel culture as this
monolithic movement to salespeople is basically
meaningless. It's not accurately representing
what's happening. There's no conspiracy. It's
the marketplace of ideas that the right holds
up as a place where ideas or jokes or bigotry
or ad campaigns or content or whatever are open
to criticism, and they're open to consequences.
So let's get away from the term cancel culture.
I use it tongue in cheek when I say, look,
it's cancel culture from the right, but it's
really a political boogeyman and it's meant to
silence voices, often marginalized voices. It's
meant to protect the status quo, particularly
when it comes to Republicans by making them
immune to the consequences of their actions
and their words. Don't fall for it. Let's actually
push back against the concept of cancel culture.